[Music]
we have money that's been damaged in a
fire in a flood it's been eaten by
insects or animals we'll evaluate and
determine how much is there and
reimburse you for it
my name is Eric Walsh I'm the assistant
manager of the muhly currency division
every year the Emilia currency division
receives about 23,000 cases people will
send money that's been somehow damaged
and we reimburse annually about 40
million dollars as a free service the
government provides that we pay dollar
in dollar out we require 51% of the note
president to pay on it and that just
protects us from paying twice on the
same note once we determine the amount
we will send a Treasury check for what
we discover we're pretty low tech here
so the tools of the trade are scissors
knives scalpels glue and tape and maybe
a pair of tweezers the most challenging
cases are usually cases that the money
has gotten wet and set for long periods
of times and will actually petrify and
be solid as a brick a lot of is the dog
ain't my money we get hundreds of those
cases you're a lot of people will hide
their money in the oven and forget about
it or they'll get it wet and put it in
the microwave and that will ignite the
currency our most infamous case took
place in the 80s and what happened was a
farmer lost his wallet in the field and
discovered that his cow had eaten it and
we always encouraged the submitter to
send in the package as it is and the
farmer sent in the cow's stomach which
we were able to retrieve the wallet firm
and reimbursed the farmer his currency
[Music]
our office consists of just 720 people
and we have 12 people that examine and
process the submissions and they do
roughly between 1,000 2,000 claims each
year we do get an increased amount of
cases after a national disaster over the
past year between the hurricanes and
wildfires on California we've reimbursed
over two million dollars we're caught up
on what a lot of people hit their low
point so any relief that you can provide
someone after they lost all their money
in a flood or after the house burned
down it's very rewarding
hopefully we're a service that you will
never need to use but in case something
does happen we're here for you
[Music]
[Music]